hi i'm lauren zima were here at the L
women in Hollywood event honoring women
like Helen Mirren Kristen Stewart and we
actually talked to Kristen about why
she's been able to open up over the past
year so you're being honored here
tonight and very deservedly so what is
your favorite quality about yourself oh
my gosh my favorite quality about myself
hmm yeah I need a really hard worker I
think that I can like out lat
I can I have endurance I mean one thing
I admire about you is you've been really
honest this year you've really opened up
about who you are what led you to kind
of becoming that honest and sharing so
much about yourself oh I think it takes
it takes a minute to sort of acclimate
to communicating with with so many
people at one time like like the masses
you know and I think it's um I think
it's I think i think it's only
beneficial like for me to have certain
pathways open and it ends up kind of
like not allowing people to misconstrue
you and you know I I know people love to
say like oh she doesn't give up like no
I totally do man so yeah I think um I
just feel a little bit more like on
inhibited or something
you